with October and full-swing there's a
chill in the air and down our spines
the more I see Halloween costumes for
sale and decorations and houses the more
it makes me think about the darker
elements of our beloved Zelda franchise
and trust me there is no shortage one of
the creepiest backstories to a people
group in the Legend of Zelda is the
sheikah we know these people as
benevolent protectors of the royal
family and that's absolutely correct in
breath of the wild we see they've spared
no expense with technological
advancements we can see the Guardians
advanced weapons meant to defend the
royal family the resurrection chamber
which was used to restore link to his
full strength and in so doing save
Hyrule and the sheikah monks who have
lived for thousands of years out of
service - hi Lea but when we study how
they arrived at some of this technology
namely their ability to preserve life
indefinitely things begin to take a
sinister tone - some of you watching
this video will mostly hold nothing new
to those people I'd advise you to share
your knowledge with those in the
comments or continue watching to see if
maybe there's something you didn't know
here but to the majority of you who have
only played breath of the wild this will
be shocking there is a dark past behind
the sheikah and today we're going to
explore high rules bloody history of
greed and hatred
to explore the chicest dark history and
understand how they discovered the
secrets to immortality we're going to go
back in time back to the ocarina of time
back to a little town called Kakariko
village this seemingly peaceful town
full of perfectly normal-looking
inhabitants is home to some of the
darkest backstory in Zelda history
before it was open to the general public
Kakariko village was much like the one
depicted in breath of the wild it was
exclusively a sheikah inhabited village
the sheikah people chose this location
because of its close proximity to Hyrule
Castle and more than likely had numerous
underground tunnels routing to and from
the castle itself prior to the events of
Ocarina of Time the sheikah leader known
as EMPA opened the village to the
general public as a way of masking what
the village once was and the things that
once happened there you see long ago in
the hyrulean civil war there arose those
that would try to dethrone the royal
family who were appointed by highly as
the family destined to protect the
Triforce and the Sacred Realm the
sheikah who are known as the shadow folk
and whose purpose is to protect the
royal family took things into their own
hands when it came to the civil war
enemies of the royal family were not
executed but rather taken to their
secret temple for interrogations or
worse I'm referring of course to the
shadow temple a dungeon that we know was
built by sheikah
based on its symbolism location and the
use of Zelda's Lullaby to unlock key
functions within the dungeon when link
explores the temple in-game you can see
many disturbing artifacts and tools that
were once used by the sheikah themselves
there are large guillotines for
execution of prisoners horrifying
monsters that may have been the result
of failed experiments skeletons whose
spirits linger on acid pools with hands
desperately reaching out and many blood
stains throughout the dungeon the
spirits of the dead within the temple
can be heard sometimes one of the most
memorable quotes from one of these
spirits is about the shadow temple
itself
it describes the shadow temple as a
gathering
Hyrule's bloody history of greed and
hatred there are numerous references to
unknown deities such as these ominous
faces in the walls or the Horned Raven
statues the Raven historically
symbolizes death and the horns are
symbolic of demons in the zelda
franchise like the horn statue in Hatano
village it is possible that the sheikah
worshipped a demon of death in this
place the temple boss bongo bongo the
phantom shadow beast is speculated to
have been a member of the sheikah that
lived in a house located where the well
stands now he is rumored to have either
betrayed or stolen from the royal family
which would have led to his torture on
the devices we see at the bottom of the
well as well as his hands being cut off
which was historically the punishment
for a thief in ancient times he could
also have made a bargain with this death
demon after his passing to then become
the dark spirit bongo bongo which Impa
tried to seal at the bottom of the well
only for him to eventually break out and
be defeated in the shadow temple by the
hero the dark things that happened in
this temple were not ordained by the
royal family at all according to the
Hyrule encyclopedia which reads that
because it stands as a symbol of high
rules dark history it is taboo for the
royal family to speak of this temple in
its horrific purpose we can infer that
the royal family most likely did not
know about its existence and upon
finding out about the horrors that
happened there is the reason why the
temple is inactive and is not used
anymore so how does this brutality
torture and bloodshed relate to the
sheikah technology we see and breath of
the wild a key component to
understanding this is that there is a
certain kind of enemy in the shadow
temple that hasn't appeared in the
timeline before ocarina of time and that
is the redead readouts are zombified
humanoid enemies that are dark brown in
appearance and wear wooden masks in this
game they appear to be blind yet can
still paralyze link with their gaze if
they hear him moving their only drive
seems to be a desire for human flesh
their presence and this unknown dungeon
speaks volumes of the atrocities
committed here the sheikah were
experimenting with their tortured
prisoners they were trying to create
eternal life and they were praying to a
death God to make it happen this may
even explain the existence of luminous
rocks which are infused with the souls
of the dead we also see that they
continue to experiment and improve their
mummification process even after the
royal family shut the shadow temple down
in the Wind Waker the redeads make
another appearance within temples but
this time they're wearing sheikah
jewelry their earrings bear an uncanny
resemblance to the bracelets that the
sheikah monks in breath the wild are
wearing giving the implication that the
sheikah were now experimenting on
themselves the newer redeads could now
see but were still mindless and only
focused on eating the living in breath
of the wild they were eventually
successful in creating redeads also
known as the monks that retained their
memories and knowledge and even created
one monk in particular that seemingly
retained all bodily function and memory
we can see from their end product that
their strivings for eternal life were
noble in the end they used the
culmination of their knowledge to create
the monks that would serve highly a
thousands of years in the future they
appear to have been successful in their
dealings with the dead but at what cost
the shadow temple stands as the reminder
of the sheikh is hatred for the enemies
of the royal family and greed of the
eternal life of the gods even though
their evil deeds ultimately led to their
ability to serve highly along after
death does this justify their dark stain
on Hyrule's history do they still have
secrets hidden under the surface we can
see in breath of the wild if these
topics interest you check out another
video I made a while back about the
sheikah and calamity Ganon I'll link it
in the description below thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please leave a like as that will
greatly help the channel out and be sure
to subscribe if you haven't already for
much more juicy content to come leave a
comment letting me know what you think
as I mentioned before October is a time
for spooky stuff so if you want more
spooky Zelda content be sure to stick
around so I've noticed recently that
either you guys are incredibly smart or
I'm just really bad at making these
thumbnail teasers but again it was guest
almost immediately by the user named
Noah in my discord server so Noah
congratulations leave us a comment below
proclaiming your victory to everybody
else and for those of you waiting for
next week's teaser know that I'm
definitely going to be making these
harder from now on I think I know what
I've been missing and I'm going to leave
fewer hands so that less people get it
right
right off the bat huge shout-out to my
newest fan art coming from the user
named either TM or shadow is fine in my
discord server this piece is especially
adorable and may actually be my current
phone background as always Thank You
patreon supporters so much for
supporting the channel and for those of
you in the discord server for letting me
be a witness to your humour theories and
talent if you're interested in the
support tiers or in joining the discord
server and chatting it up with the best
of us then please visit the description
below for links to both of these things
that's all I've got for you today so as
always you guys have a great rest of
your day keep it chilly folks this is
massive and a bandits signing out peace
[Music]